[Music]
space jam
in theaters and on hbo max july 16th
this summer the sequel to the iconic and
now
25 year old space jam featuring michael
jordan will hit
theaters this time the sequel revolves
around nba superstar lebron james and
will make some changes compared to the
original
for the most part the animated click
around bugs bunny and the others will
appear unchanged
but individual characters have been
adapted to the spirit of the times
or have been removed altogether bugs
bunny's girlfriend lola for example it
was quite revealing in the original is
to be visually toned down a bit director
malcolm the elise said it was
particularly important not to sexualize
the character who is
well known from children's films and the
way that was still the case in 1996
according to lead is politically
incorrect and inappropriate to put a
crop top on an animated bunny
instead in keeping with the spirit of
the times they want to promote the
portrayal of self-confident female
characters
more news regarding lola states that she
will be involved with the wonder woman
universe in the new space gem
as lee confirms she hangs out with
wonder woman's amazons for example
furthermore the decision was made to
completely remove the skunk
pepe le pew this is in spite of the fact
that his scene was already shot in the
summer of 2019
on the then director terence nance in
which pepe made a prominent appearance
as deadline has found out that scene
involved a female bartender who is quiet
and snared touched and kissed by pippi
after she
successfully pushes him away pepe
jokingly comments to his fellow
cartoonists that a restraining order has
already been filed against him from
earlier days
after a new york times columnist openly
called pippi an example of rape culture
those responsible warner thought the
scene was too risky how do you view the
whole thing
are you happy about lola's fresh look
and the removal of pippy
or do you feel the whole discussion is a
bit overdone and you would like to see
the old familiar characters back
let us know in the comments the expected
release date of space jam
a new legacy is july 16th 2021
[Music]